- Last night, I saw something
that I never thought
I would ever see on American soil.
It was the stuff of tin-pot
dictators in banana republics.
As you probably know,
throughout the entire country,
our protests against police brutality
and systemic unfairness and racism.
So of course, because this is 2020,
the thing that was used
to fight those protesting,
that unfairness and brutality,
was yet more unfairness and brutality.
I never thought I would ever see anything
like what happened last night in America.
What I saw last night was
a threat to our democracy,
not foreign, but domestic.
A violation of rights,
of freedoms, and of laws
by the very people who are supposed
to protect and execute those laws.
Lafayette Square is a place
that I know very, very well.
I worked downtown for years,
and I would often go to Lafayette Park,
for a coffee or to have lunch outside, and
it's a beautiful park, right
in front of the White House.
It's also the site of many protests.
There are actually protests there,
basically 365 days a year,
there are people who
literally camp out intense.
And given its proximity
to the White House,
it makes sense as one of the
clear protest sites of choice.
There have been protests
there for decades,
if not hundreds, literally
hundreds of years.
And while President
Trump was giving a speech
about domination, he gave
the order to clear out
all of the protesters who were at
and in front of Lafayette Park.
President Trump's speech
began shortly after 6 p.m.
He gave the order to clear
out the park at 6:35 p.m.
It was a sign of a peaceful protest.
Not all of these protests
have been peaceful,
but the one in Lafayette Park was.
It was attended by peaceful
protesters, by the media.
- As we speak, I am dispatching
thousands and thousands
of heavily armed soldiers,
military personnel,
and law enforcement offices
to stop the rioting, looting,
vandalism, assaults, and the
wanton destruction of property.
- And at 6:35 p.m. he gave the
order to round everyone up,
to clear them out.
And someone whether it was the President
or those acting under his orders,
tear gassed the protesters,
shot them with rubber munitions,
and generally just beat the.
Federal officers armed to the teeth,
wearing protective riot
gear dressed in all black,
clad with plastic shields and backed up
by what was effectively cavalry on horses,
began rounding everyone
up and pushing them out.
This was the sort of tactic
that was designed to get violent.
Years of study of crowd
control have shown that
the way to de-escalate
a situation like this
is effectively to do the exact opposite.
And get these federal
officers wearing riot gear
effectively tried to bum
rush out peaceful protesters.
They came out swinging, literally.
There's a video circulating of what
one of these federal officers did
to an Australian news crew,
after running towards the protesters.
This particular officer started punching
and using his shield as a weapon.
He hits the Australian cameraman
directly in the stomach,
beats him up, sends him on his way.
We have video footage not only of
what one of the protesters saw happening
to this Australian camera crew,
but also from the camera crew itself.
- We are really surrounded by the police
and you really saw the way that I dealt
with my cameraman team.
They're quite violent.
- What was the reason for expelling
these peaceful protesters
who were exercising
their constitutional right to protest?
The President wanted a photo op
at a church across the street.
He wanted to be able to
walk from the White House,
out the front door, which is rarely done,
through Lafayette Park,
to stand in front of St John's Church,
a non-partisan place of worship.
Reports are that little to no warning
was given to the protesters ahead of time.
And that it was coordinated so that
he could end his speech
in the Rose Garden,
and walk directly out to the church.
- I'm going to pay my respects
to a very, very special place.
Thank you very much.
- Of course, when he got to the church
for his photo opportunity, he
turned his back on the church.
He didn't pray, he didn't reflect.
He didn't even open the
Bible he carried with him.
He took it out, held it upside down,
move it around in different ways
to get the best photo opportunity,
stood in front of the
church for a minute or two,
told the media that it was a Bible.
- [Interviewer] Is that your Bible?
- It's a bible.
- And then left.
He cleared out the protesters
before the 7 p.m. DC
curfew went into effect.
And then in the ultimate irony,
the President of law and order
stayed past the curfew
to get his photo op.
And of course, the cherry on top is that,
after the crowd was being dispersed,
the federal government employed
military Black Hawk
helicopters in a show of force,
flying dozens of feet above the crowd
in an incredibly dangerous maneuver
that I can't recall anything like it
ever happening on American soil.
Nothing about the President's speech,
or his photo opportunity
was about reconciliation,
about progress, about repair,
or even about amelioration or
de-escalation of the protests.
It was calculated only to
inflame, to make things worse,
to own the libs while
desecrating a religious site,
while blaspheming the Bible
and beating out of the protesters.
And we saw the end result of
this callous move this morning,
just mere hours after it happened.
The White House releases a video montage
set to music the next day,
a campaign stunt brought
to you by tear gassing.
Some people like Scott Walker
had the audacity to say that,
no one else would have the guts
to do what President Trump did,
to walk out in front of the crowd.
Yeah, it sure takes a real man
to order other people with guns
to fire munitions to its civilians.
American citizens exercising
their constitutional right to protest,
and then walk between 100 armed guards
and Secret Service members
for a two minute photo op
after clearing the area.
Real guts.
Now, I've been referring
to these armed guards
as federal officers,
because all reports show
that these were not DC cops.
DC police generally know
how to do crowd control.
And while we all have issues
with the DC police department,
the Metropolitan Police Department.
I'd like to think that
DC cops wouldn't stand
for being puppets of the
President so he can get a photo op
while infringing on people's
constitutional rights.
Apparently, the DC police
were given minimal notice,
they were surprised as everyone else.
And one of the ultimate
ironies of this whole situation
is that not only were the
DC police totally uninformed
about this maneuver,
but one of the priests
who was one of the proprietors
of St John's Church,
where the President wanted to
have his photo opportunity,
was expelled from the area
so the President could stand there.
Mayor Bowser, the mayor of DC confirmed
that nothing in this particular situation,
warranted the use of munitions
against the protesters,
or the tactics of the riot police.
- What we saw was before the curfew time,
munitions were released on people
who didn't seem to have
provoked any attack.
- And all of the people in
this particular area of DC,
were in fact, peacefully protesting.
On this channel, I
tried to give both sides
when there are both sides to a story,
they're usually are.
And in this particular case, yes,
there were looting and riots
in other parts of the country,
but they weren't at the White House.
No one is supporting the
rioters and the looters,
but that's not what was going on here.
And it could also be the case
that there are bad faith rioters
and protesters and looters
who are part of an
otherwise peaceful protest,
that's not the issue here.
The issue here is that
unequivocally draconian tactics
were used on peaceful protesters.
Before curfew started, the stories
about the violent protests
and the unlawful looting
and rioting deserve their own place
on the front page of the New York Times.
But those stories as of today deserve
to be at the bottom of the front page,
because the headline
that should be ringing
in every house in America
is that the President
of the United States
ordered draconian measures
to expel peaceful protesters
so he could get a photo op.
I don't know if it's possible
to overdose on metaphors,
but today is actually Election Day in DC.
I don't know.
Something about this whole situation,
feels different to me on
many different fronts.
Maybe there are more cameras
out today than in the past,
and maybe we're just seeing
more of what was already there,
and I'm sure that's the case.
But I also wonder if
there is more police abuse
that we're seeing as well.
When you declare war on America,
what you get is a war on America,
that when you have federal
officers and police
dress up like soldiers, they
start acting like soldiers.
I think in part, what we're seeing today
is the result of years of
the President's statements.
Like, if you have a suspect in custody,
feel free to rough them up.
Don't be too nice on them.
The press is the enemy of the people,
and that we need to dominate protesters,
making no distinction between looters
and peaceful protesters.
Words have consequences.
The President has a bully pulpit.
And we shouldn't be surprised when people
actually follow the words
of an authority figure
like the President of the United States.
Even though I am a relatively new adopter
of the city of Washington
DC as their home,
I have adopted it.
I chose to live here.
It's my home, and it's
where I'm gonna stay.
DC is a city that has been scarred
by the 1968 riots in many ways.
It's only in the last say 10 years
that it's really begun to heal.
And I've seen nothing in
the last 24 to 48 hours
that has done anything
to make things better.
And the actions that were taken today,
threaten that fragile piece.
It threatens DC sovereignty, as it were.
DC is not a state, we
don't have a governor.
Often, the city can't
refuse federal troops.
And we don't have the
representatives, the senators,
the governors and all
of the other privileges
that the other states have to be able
to fight the federal government
in the way that they can.
This is one of the reasons why
DC statehood is so important.
Just yesterday morning,
and those naive days,
I was reading an opinion piece
by noted conservative
pundit George F Will.
He wrote in The Washington Post,
starting by referring to
the President's tweets
about Joe Scarborough stating,
those who think our unhinged
President's recent mania
about a murder two decades
ago that never happened,
represents his moral nadir,
have missed the lessons of his life.
There is no such thing as rock bottom.
So assume that the worst is yet to come.
I read those words, and I honestly thought
that George Will was overreacting.
I thought it was a little histrionic.
And then of course, because it's 2020,
we all have to eat our own words.
And then Lafayette Park happened.
Yesterday, the President said--
- I am your President of law and order.
- This is a President who just weeks ago,
abdicated all federal responsibility
regarding COVID and the Coronavirus,
calling it a states rights issue,
and that the governor should
do something about it.
And now when it suits him,
he aggrandizes himself
control of all of the federal
officers and the military,
so that he can do a photo opportunity.
- If a city or state
refuses to take the actions
that are necessary to
defend the life and property
of their residents, then I will deploy
the United States Military
and quickly solve the problem for them.
- And he abuses the
authority of the military.
This is the kind of show of force
that actually escalates
into more violence,
which is obviously exactly
what some people want.
Now, things can and will get better.
It might not feel like it,
but police shootings nationally
are down and going lower.
Shootings of unarmed
people are going down,
and accountability is going up.
But for things to get better,
we're going to have to
be proactive about it.
And I have to admit that
it's even hard for me
an eternal optimist,
to be optimistic about,
the things that I'm seeing on TV,
last night, today, and probably tomorrow.
But what can we do?
Well, first, record everything.
If you're going to take to
the streets, do so peacefully.
And please stop the looters.
Civil Disobedience not only exists
to fight the government itself,
but also to fight your fellow man
when they're being unreasonable.
And if you are going
out, please wear a mask.
I really, really hope
we're out of the woods
with respect to COVID.
But this could turn bad.
We might have to go into quarantine again.
I'm truly conflicted, because I think
a lot of this cause is just
and it's fighting injustice,
but the consequences are real.
So please be responsible for yourself.
And with respect to other protesters,
do what you can to not
only protected them,
but to protect other people's property
and to record injustice
wherever you see it,
and to publish it so that we
have at least a record of it.
To the members of the armed
citizens who may be asked
to turn their weapons against
other American citizens,
I ask you to reflect and think about
your actions before you take them.
That the highest form
of civil disobedience
is to reject an unlawful order.
And you may be asked to do so.
It's not fair, but we all have
to play the hands that were dealt.
And that unfortunately,
the Federal military
is probably going to be the
tip of the spear on this.
The same goes for the
DC police department,
the Metropolitan Police Department.
You don't have to do what
we're seeing officers on TV do,
there's always a choice.
And for everyone else,
continue speaking out.
I am continually astonished
by the outpouring of support
that people have given to this
cause and and rightfully so.
And we're Of course, hearing
from the usual suspects.
It's no surprise the people
that are in support of these things.
But there are some groups of
people who I haven't heard from
that I would like to.
Where are all of those
Second Amendment supporters
who were so vocal just
a couple of weeks ago
and who are so silent now,
when you were asking for
a tyrannical government to fight against,
well, now is your chance.
If you stay at home, thinking
that the Second Amendment
is more important than
the First Amendment,
I feel sorry for you.
And I think that you should
come to the conclusion that,
your fantasy of being a
good guy with a gun fighting
a tyrannical government, is just that.
It's just a fantasy.
If you were willing to
protest a few weeks ago,
you should be willing
to fight police abuse
and systemic violence out there today.
And where are all of those
freedom of religion folks?
The irony of what happened
yesterday is that,
in order to clear out the protesters,
the federal government used
federal officers to clear out
the actual priest who was in
charge of St George's church,
and then the President held
out a Bible without opening it,
without reading from it.
If that's not blasphemy,
I don't know what is.
Why aren't you being vocal
about this abuse of religion
for political ends?
And where are all of the folks
who claim to care about law and order?
What we saw last night
was pure lawlessness.
Just because the federal
government does it,
doesn't mean that it should.
And it doesn't mean that it was legal
and doesn't mean that it was right.
If you care about a rule of
law that applies to everyone,
you ought to be appalled at
what happened last night.
And besides speaking out, if
you could donate to the ACLU,
I'll put a link in the description,
I would greatly appreciate it.
I think there are a lot of
folks who are going to need
some good legal representation
before all of this is out,
and I will give to the ACLU as well.
By now you've probably seen this photo.
The lights were dark at
the White House last night.
But the lights have been dark
at the White House for a long time.
Let's do what we can to
bring the light back.